foreign
and it went over a million next
notification I got it said like The Rock
Dwayne Johnson The Rock yeah yeah like
Yeah The Rock yeah I just I looked at it
and then immediately just like put it
down like that didn't happen so it
turned out I had my first panic attack
that was terrible thought I was dying
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney's show show we talk
about your mental health your emotional
health what's going on in your marriage
what's going on on in your bedroom
what's going on with your kids whatever
you got going on in your world
my promise is I'll walk alongside you
and we'll figure out the next right step
for two decades thousands and thousands
of people I've sat with when when the
wheels have fallen off
talk to groups across the country
what do we do next and I don't know much
but I do know how to sit with folks and
say all right let's figure out what to
do next I'm so grateful for you all just
giving up your time just sit with us and
um listen to the show and apply some of
these things into your life uh yesterday
I was in Arkansas speaking at a
university
and after I spoke I came and sat down
and the president of the University
followed up and was on the stage
and I won't embarrass him because I know
it would but a an extraordinary
man showed up
walked all the way down the aisle in
front of everybody wearing his
um facilities and maintenance shirt and
he's sitting next and he just leaned
over and said I listened to the show
every single day and it's helped my
marriage it's helped my family it's
helped me thank you so much and I just I
was almost I was trying not to weep as I
was able just to receive his hug such a
gift but that's what he shows for folks
who are just trying to do a little bit
better in their home just trying to
figure out what comes next so if you
want to be on the show go to John
deloney.com ask a-s-k and if you don't
want to be on the show thank you for
listening thank you for sharing it and
for your fancy reviews all right today
very special episode incredible episode
if you are an Instagram person
surely you know who the Kardashians are
and right after the Kardashians
you know who Jefferson Fisher is
Jefferson Fisher is a
um a really renowned trial attorney
um young guy in Houston Texas or just
outside of Houston
and what's unique about Jefferson is he
was one of my students when I was a dean
of students at a law school now I say
that
I came in and he was already a third
year student who basically him and a
couple of others ran the law school and
he already was brilliant already was an
incredible scholar an incredible
um about to be licensed attorney so when
I say like he was one of my students you
know I can take no credit for his
nunchuck skills but I do like to walk
around and tell everybody he was one of
my students because he has become one of
the most followed people on Instagram he
is a an attorney who has decided to take
the skills that attorneys learn on how
to deconstruct have hard conversations
how to make people annoyed how to get
people to say certain things and he's
taking those skills and he gives very
simple bite-sized lessons on how to be a
better dad how to be a better husband
how to be a better wife how to be a
better neighbor and Community member and
as you can imagine they've just blown up
the other day I was I was texting him
back and forth because the number one
comment on his post was from The Rock
The Rock
you know that guy who I have about the
same upper body so anyway Jefferson
um was here in Nashville
um somebody that I just care a lot about
I have higher high respect for and um
I've just been amazing it's been amazing
to watch him grow up if you will from a
law student to somebody who now has a
team of attorneys working for them and
more importantly or as importantly is
now taking his message
um
Global which is just just powerful what
we talk about on the show we talk about
deconstructing hard conversations how to
have them
what does anxiety and panic look like in
somebody that's not a mental health
professional somebody that's got it all
together somebody that would set would
tell you this doesn't happen to me and
it does
um how to be a better dad how to be a
better husband we talk about all of it
um he's incredibly well spoken it's
embarrassing to talk next to him um when
you're a mumbler like me and he's so
clear and concise
um because that's he's clearing concise
for a living but he's also an incredible
dad an incredible husband to his amazing
also attorney wife
um I just can't wait for you just to to
be a fly on the wall of this
conversation my time with my good friend
former student and guy who I'm now in
awe of Jefferson Fisher stay tuned
it's not uncommon at all
um like over the last 20 years I've
thousands of students I've interacted
with and so over the last few years as
I've transitioned into this wild new
world yeah um students will reach out
and say hey man it's good to see you or
it's so weird seeing you whatever and
that's all awesome right so you reach
out and I get this note and it's like uh
hey man it's on Instagram on Instagram
proud of you you're doing awesome it's
great to see you and I was like ah
thanks yeah yeah but I treated it kind
of like oh that's cute and like kind of
perfect and I felt that I was like Hey
there you go you go man go buddy yeah
and you mentioned something like I'm
kind of Dipping my toes into this world
yeah yeah then uh send that message off
and then I go to it
and I'm like
two million who is this guy's like super
famous and so I started going through
your stuff yeah and it's it's
extraordinary right thanks man the main
reason I would have you here one is
um
almost all of the people that reach out
to our show are facing boundary issues
with their in-laws or facing a husband
who's hasn't hit them yet but it's
abusive right or they're staring at
their seven-year-old and their 14 year
old they don't know what to do right or
the two-year-old and three-year-old yeah
or their sex life falling apart and they
don't know
how to have a conversation about what
happens next yeah what you have emerged
like like almost overnight which we all
know is a Decades of practice right is
like really a world-class
teacher on
hey say it like this instead of like
this and it's it's so counter-cultural
that it's and it's such a gift to people
and you've got a clear way and I'm
always telling the folks who who watch
the show I mean if you get pissed off at
your wife or husband there's nothing
wrong with you right you probably got a
generation of wiring and genetics and
the way you your parents treated you
like you've got all these things what
you don't have a set of skills a set of
tools correct and so I thought this
would be awesome to run some scenarios
by you and you can teach me decision
this is not my family because I'm
perfect this is clearly for everybody
right right right right so the person X
grows up in a home whose mom's real
domineering dad was real quiet just hid
behind a newspaper by his behind his
iPad and there's this inner rage that
happens then your wife comes home 20
years later and that same story just
kicks up again right yeah so husband
gets home he drives up the driveway
wreck real fast dinner was at six they
had just had like a a marriage Retreat a
few months before where he was going to
work really hard on being on time
because it she felt his wife felt
disrespected right he drives up he's 45
minutes late
and he's already preparing the story
right and he was at work but he's also
just kind of scrolling on crap and
joking around and laughing or whatever
and he actually feels bad that he's late
but then he also feels pissed that she's
gonna get mad that he was late because
I've been working so hard and I can't
just spend 15 freaking minutes talking
to my buddies right yeah so he walks in
the two kids are there already halfway
through the meal and then he gets that
mix of anger and shame like I should be
here with my family and how dare they
start without me it happens at the same
time yeah right
and he looks at her and she just has
that look like
I thought things gonna be different and
he launches into a story well dude I was
walking out the door and then so and so
came by
clearly making this up yeah and she
knows he's lying and she's at a Breaking
Point and she thinks I got him and
suddenly we're at a proxy war over here
and we're fighting about you lied and
you uh never tell the truth like this
whole thing happened yeah what are some
ways that a she can defuse that
situation yeah and B actually get to a
place of where we can interact right
it's a hard spot to be you find yourself
on the same Battlefield that you felt
like you were you had already won yeah
you know you have this kind of this
one-on-one that's hey we had this
meeting of the minds we had an
understanding and then something happens
and you fall back into ordinary life and
all of a sudden you realize
we don't even know each other again it's
almost sense of betrayal very much so in
this the sense of I thought we had a
pact I thought we had a baseline
connection and all of a sudden you
realize that connection is is broken
like in a like a light switch Yeah if
you're gonna have a light on there's
that circuitry that connects them
but if it's switched off then it's then
it's broken then then it's dark and then
you're going I can't see where are you
where am I and you have that sense of
I'm just feeling around and and that's
scary for both people and if I'm sitting
in that room you know at a thousand foot
View and I'm looking at this family that
is going through the same thing both of
our family I mean everybody's family
yeah I mean I can anybody can relate to
that
um what comes to mind is three things
one you can't have that conversation in
front of the kids I believe you're in a
similar mindset of there are certain
things you talk about in front of your
kids and certain things you you don't
because and from what I recall I mean
growing up if my parents got in an
argument
I thought my life was over you know what
I mean like like if they were in an
argument
I mean even with my kids if my wife and
I are
just doing something easy they're like
what's what's happening yeah yeah that
shakes them they don't need that second
of all is there is a power and timing
and a power and discernment and knowing
when to have that conversation so you
know it's not then and then you know
it's later this guy's coming in she
already knows that he's late he knows
what he did wrong is there's no question
right and so whenever he comes in she
has a choice at that moment
do I become the attacker
or do I choose later in that moment
to have a conversation to connect again
to see if this is something he's willing
to fix and you have that's hard man very
hard yeah because I want to hit him
there's nothing easy about it but but
you play it out you play it out that
what's she gonna do she stands up oh
really you're going to be late oh okay
yeah I guess it's gonna be cold uh go
ahead and do it in the microwave hey
kids guess dad didn't want to come home
for dinner you go I mean and there it's
off and then all of a sudden you are the
bad one yeah you you've already ruined
it and if somebody is a scolded dog
coming in there's no use
kicking them right then I mean they
already know and so what I would tell
that Mom
is you enjoy time with your kids you
finish dinner you let's let's do bath
time let's let's say prayers let's get
them in bed and then you come back and
sit down
and say how was your day
that's a power move man that's the flex
of like you saying that even makes me go
yeah yeah but imagine
but imagine the the strength that you
would also show oh yeah when you sit
back and you go
how's your day I mean that husband's
going it's a power vacuum right yeah can
you just please yell at me yeah yeah can
you yell at me like I already know what
I did wrong can you can we just what's
up with you yeah but that ability to sit
back and
um have that bird's eye view of I can
I become more confident and I become
stronger
the less that I put out I mean in the
scenarios I give is it's very much if I
add ice cubes to the water
or you know ice cubes of the drink you
diluted and many times we add way too
many ice cubes we want to start off
being angry we want to start off saying
all the wrong things and when it's
concentrated
it's it's you're much more potent it's
it's not easy I also think you give
somebody
well two things I'm going to touch on
one there's been some kind of some
turning in the psychological literature
over the last decade or so about
um
it's really important actually to have
some level of disagreement in front of
your kids because there's a generation
taught go fight in the back bedroom yeah
and what you ended up with a group a
generation of young people that started
you know having getting married and then
they'd have their first big fight and
they hadn't had no reference point right
oh this is over yeah we're breaking up
we're getting divorced we've been
married nine months but that's also
you liar you like that she's ready to
like come full force don't do that in
front yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and and
so the husband comes in and what he's
wanting to do when he starts and he's
already got a story he's going right so
what he's wanting to do is control that
narrative before she even has it out
you'll see that a lot and you have a
disagreement with somebody they want to
they'll back up and back up and they'll
say okay I came in and when I came in
you did this and then that made me say
this that made me say this right and so
they then become a character in their
story ah and that's what they're doing
they've become they've become the author
and the lead yeah you know and and the
victim all in one and that's where you
have the chance to continue to pull
apart if if they're really invested in
fixing that and owning that I mean
because you're catching them in a lie
essentially is what you're doing but
there's also a moment where if you're
truly invested and this is hard man
especially if you've been in an abusive
relationship over time if you're truly
invested in healing there is a chance
that
at 4 48 as he was getting ready to leave
his boss came in and said I have to have
this before you walk out the door right
and no text could have that happen
um even though y'all had said hey if
you're gonna be late just shoot me a
text like the whole thing is Avalanches
on you and you get upset you get
frustrated that approach does give an
Avenue for Humanity that's right for me
to say give it a chance no really
I was texting and driving because I was
trying to catch my wife at the hospital
I wasn't just this out of control yeah
right yeah so there's some there's some
Humanity there and also man it just
vacuums power oh yeah yeah you become
you become the most credible
in the room yeah when that happens yeah
and so a lot of the times you know as as
an attorney I might have somebody who
makes a snide comment in the courtroom
and one of my favorite moves is let's
say let's say you would we're at let's
say we're at a deposition right now
you're on the other side and I'm
cross-examining you just like Dustin
kind of did
you said something like hey all you all
you attorneys are the worst you know
what you're the worst thing that could
happen in this Society
my favorite move
is for me to just kind of take it in and
go well
maybe so
that right there is just that little
maybe so okay
I give them nothing in return I dropped
their words off a cliff they go but but
you were supposed to catch that yeah I
said I oh it's on the floor yeah yeah
they're like no no you you were supposed
to catch that and throw it back at me I
said no I don't it's it's in the trash
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go pick that
back up and so it's that that that
thought of you are completely within
your own control of how defensive you
get so if you cannot measure your
reaction then you measure your response
and you do that in a way that
always puts you as the most credible the
most confident in the room but what a
power Flex every time because it's
they're expecting me to say oh really
we're the worst in in the world what
about you yeah yeah that's exactly right
yeah me what about you yeah because the
class it's like a kid coming up and
hitting an adult as hard as they can and
just not moving yeah and the kids like
that's all I got yeah right I mean it's
such a yeah I'm not going to push you
back I don't have to right you're not
gonna react oh that's even worse okay
what you've given us is
I think one of the most important and
poignant and hardest lessons in human
relationships which is nobody can truly
make you do anything
and man that's hard to learn yeah all
right we'll be right back
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
hey this is deloney I hope you all are
doing well listen sometimes it's hard to
get our brains to turn off and I know
what I'm talking about I am the king of
racing thoughts they've kept me up at
night they've got me up early and kept
me from connecting with people I love if
you find your thoughts start to race
right before bed or during other super
inconvenient times a great way to make
those racing thoughts slow down or stop
is to talk them through and therapy gave
me a place to do that so I could get off
the negative thought treadmill learn
positive coping skills set healthy
boundaries and find some mental and
emotional peace and it can help you too
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is
convenient because it's entirely online
so it's flexible and can fit into your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge so take a break from
Raising Thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
how do I learn and I think it's a set of
skills but if you grew up in a house
where your job was the emotional
regulation of the adults if it was your
job to make sure your dad didn't get mad
or mom was always saying hey you all
need to do this because Dad's coming
home and he's you know how he gets when
or Dad's like oh dude your mom's about
to get set off if you all don't get this
the kids learn oh it's our job to make
sure Mom and Dad are okay right which is
a weight they can't no kid can carry no
that transitions to adulthood either
you're a spouse who takes [__] on as
your responsibility to make sure your
husband or wife is happy at all times
yeah or there's such an inner age that
you
circle the wagons around your own life
and you're gonna get the life that you
want whether you got to borrow up to the
hill you're going to drive that car
you're gonna live in that neighborhood
in that house you're gonna marry this
person you can do whatever you want
ultimately the grenades that are thrown
back and forth are well you made me fill
in the blank or you said this thing so I
couldn't just sit there and you did it
like um everything is I have to or I'm
in responsive
the greatest Flex I've ever heard in my
life ever ever was somebody was having a
conversation with Jocko and they said so
you're walking with your family down the
street right former Navy SEAL jacked
human beings just being in his presence
is like
yeah yeah I I need to go and on top he's
in world class world world class Jiu
Jitsu player so
he guy says so somebody comes down the
sidewalk and just confronts you and your
family and it's like what's up man we
got a problem he goes what do you do
and driving said well I reach over and
grab my wife's hand and my daughter's
hand and we would just go to the side of
the street and go that way and head home
and the guy was flabbergasted it was
like what
but what about defending your wife's
honor and like your kids
and he said two really important things
number one he said
there are a handful of men on planet
Earth who can defeat me in hand-to-hand
combat and they do that for a living and
he goes
what honor do I get out of beating up
some guy on the sidewalk yeah and then
he said something that was super
powerful he said if I
have to wait until that moment to show
my wife that I honor her I have failed
her in every way the smartest thing is
to get my family home safely I don't
know if this guy's got a friend with
guns or with bottles or with like I
don't know right he's gonna go home and
I remember thinking that ability to step
out of Chaos in that moment right that's
an egregious example on the street with
a Navy SEAL
99 of us are at home yeah and our wife
says that thing or a husband does that
thing again right every time our kids
come in and say this thing
and every defense mechanism we have
gears up and here we go right you had to
cultivate over years
an attorney's job is just to get and I
you're at a place now I guarantee you
they're like I'll get Jefferson I'll get
it yeah you know what I mean like yeah
I'll set them up oh it's a challenge now
it's a game yeah like uh like and you
know there's so much ego in the legal
profession I'll get Jefferson I'd set
him off what are some skills that people
can practice to begin to back up detach
as Jacob to disassociate to to take
myself from in the middle of the
hurricane to 30 000 feet where it's safe
yeah what I tell my clients when that
happens because I train them because
somebody's about to try and knock them
off kilter like you started with
I have to train them and how not to let
that happen yeah and you you're training
people who have been like oh yeah their
kids are not alive anymore oh yeah or
they they think they had a leg amputated
like you're dealing with people who have
are highly charged right extremely
highly charged people who who do have a
chip on their shoulders somebody who has
been a victim of something but it's it's
even more than that I mean I am hired to
handle other people's problems I get
hired to handle somebody else's beef
that's not even mine so somebody's other
side's mad at me I'm like hey I didn't
cause this there's a hundred bucks yeah
but I'll be glad to step in right and
then on the other side there's another
attorney who's been hired to make me
look bad like that's their sole purpose
it's to ruin my case yeah you know and
and that's and you have to coordinate
and balance
how I'm gonna have them communicate
because how they represent themselves
is everything and how they communicate
and so what I always tell them is
let your first word be your breath the
first word out of your mouth is your
breath and so when I instead of just say
take a breath I say no
make your first word I turn it into I
mean like the affirmative yes here's an
action yeah that's that's what first
thing you say is your breath
and because so often I mean and you know
this that our body's tight our shoulders
it gets up in our ears like we're just a
dog with you know the back of the hair
standing up ready to go but when you
take a breath I just was you said it I
did it and my body went yeah right it's
physiologic right yeah oh yeah it's huge
well yeah you're telling your body
there's no threat oh God you know yeah
and so too often when I respond to
somebody in a way that is equaling their
energy somebody comes in and makes a
comment at me I have the choice in that
moment do I
do I try and man up I try and oh you
want to have this measuring contest but
if if I'm able to take their power away
without doing any of that because I'm
I'm telling my body and I'm telling them
you're not a threat to me and like I
physically I'm telling my body they're
not a threat and with my words you know
just like saying maybe so or I'll say
you know well maybe you're right
oh they go uh what do I do with this
what do I what do I say now if I tell
them maybe you're right you know they go
all right
uh I mean they have no words they have
no words I mean too often then then they
come back and later apologize yeah
because now that now they're thinking
you know what else why'd I say that yeah
but but had I responded defensively they
got exactly what they want then then
I've Justified their next step then so
if I come back with something you know
with a another comment that gets
defensive that's offensive to them I've
given the rules of Zinger
I've just given them a stepladder that's
all I've done I mean they they they're
throwing it out hoping that I take a
bite you know and if you if you don't
bite it then what you do you just kind
of reel it back up and go home yeah
nothing happened but there there is I
mean
not to generalize on multiple fronts
here but I'm going to yeah you're a
Texas male like I am right and there's a
and I'm using that like
broadly speaking there is a wired in
response it's like you can't talk to me
like that like yeah so for men and women
or I'm tired of taking this or I've been
taking this my whole life or yeah there
is a truth to
I'm going to respond in in the in the
moment like this because I'm playing a
different game and I'm playing I'm I'm
working towards an outcome right
but there's also that very human I'm
driving home and I can't believe that
dude said that yeah man that made me mad
yeah so going back to that previous uh
the previous law experiment yeah there's
a wife and her husband comes home and
she's lying and she sits down and
immediately her first words are her
breath
[Music]
how's your day
not in a it's a check-in yeah not in a
sarcastic way but a genuine like how's
your day
there's still that
you told me you're gonna be on time yeah
and now you're gonna rattle off some
story yeah yeah right hey how do you
give a process on the way home I can
release I can have them release that
kind of frustration it's not the way you
say it's what it's what your words are
and for example so this woman she takes
a big breath
husband sitting in maybe he's standing
up by the sink he has he hasn't said
anything he knows he's not right kids
are in bed she's at the kitchen table
and she takes a breath and goes
so how was your day
he goes all right blah blah blah blah
blah blah
can we talk about something
this is something important to me you
frame the conversation and so about her
not him you guys was genius yeah yeah
and then you say one she's she's not
starting with you did it again
it's gone he has to go to war now yeah
yeah he had no choice that's right but
when you say you frame the conversation
of I like to talk about something that's
important to me and I know that it's
important to you too
and my hope is that it when we get done
talking
you know we're gonna be able to you're
gonna be able to come back tomorrow and
we're gonna all have dinner the right
way
and you you just have that that
you say what do you do with that
frustration
it's not the emotions it's that you need
to get out it's the words because you
feel like they don't understand me
they're not acknowledging me they don't
understand how important this is and
you're not going to relay that message
with your emotion when you when you come
when you come at it strong like that
they're not hearing your words they're
hearing your tone it's physiological
dead body's responding before they've
even thought of you you got it so and
most of the time we're I mean we're
horrible predictors of what our message
sounds like and looks like and feels
yeah yeah you could say why are you
yelling me I'm not yelling at you right
right yeah but I'm going I'm looking for
ways that you're hurting me yes and you
can say hey you're late why are you
yelling right and now yeah and oh yeah
that and that's a very like classic it's
you're just diverting the attention
you're deflecting and all of a sudden
it's uh and I know if I think maybe I've
done something on this before it's like
well I'm sorry that I'm such a horrible
person person
yeah and that's like it's so gross it's
so manipulative but it happens all the
time well I'm sorry I'm just trying to
be a good husband I'm sorry that I have
to work so much and it's just straight
manipulation yeah is what that is
and the the way to
back up is how so if somebody were to
come in and say like some I'm just
trying to think I'm thinking of a
particular co-worker who would look at
me go sorry I'm just so dumb and I don't
know everything
that's just it's just such a passive
weak move and I have an Impulse to yeah
be like no you know what man but it's
backing out and me saying that's
that's
that's some good on his life not mine oh
that's that's a perfect way to say it so
whenever they put out that kind of
apology it's not an apology it's it's um
it's a bunch of slathering of sun lotion
on their guilt and they're just trying
to cover it up because your son is
beaming right right so they're trying to
protect 50 SPF because they know that
you could be coming in hot and they're
wanting to deflect you anything else
because once you say that sorry that I'm
such a Negative quality self-deprecating
whatever they're hoping that you take
the bait and go you're not terrible oh
you always think I'm terrible I mean you
always and then like remember that one
time and boom is gone yeah like that
you've lost you've lost the moment but
instead if you're able to say I don't
need you to
apologize
for how you're you're feeling but you
can't apologize for coming in late
you know the the ability to to shift
that because you're caught one you're
calling it out second of all you're
still maintaining control it got you the
third thing that is a gift and this is
doesn't feel like a gift in the moment
but for
especially for people in professional
relationships or romantic relationships
you're actually giving me a road map
and we expect people especially when
we're mad to read our minds and to know
exactly what they did and why they did
it and how you can make me feel better
because it's your job right yeah by
saying
you don't apologize for how you feel
right I do need to apologize because you
were late yep I just gave you a laser
path right and you can choose to follow
it or not but I have to have enough
control over my emotions to know what
the actual issue is here and what I'm
going for here and is it to win is it to
crush you is it to catch you yeah or is
it
to have dinner as a family around this
table that's my long-term goal here
right oh yeah you just give somebody a
path
yeah but man you got that takes a lot of
humility to take that path but it's just
not easy I think it's a gift it well
yeah it is not it's not easy and even
for somebody who practices it it's it's
still it's it's not it's not easy
because you you want that immediate you
know just guttural reaction to yell to
fight to get after it never ends well I
mean it just doesn't because what
happens let's here we go I like this so
you you you and I get an argument we're
I mean we're after it we're saying
terrible things to each other I'm my
face looks mad I'm bowed up you're bowed
up or husband or wife you're saying
horrible things bring the stuff up in
the past
what happens there's a there's a break
where everybody says I'm out of here
different room whatever
what happens when you come back
your Tone's a little softer
you're slower with your words
you had
I didn't mean what I said there I I was
just I was frustrated with
when you know
our our son did x y z and it just makes
me feel like a failure that I I couldn't
do I can't get him to and and all of a
sudden you realize that what they were
initially mad about was nothing even
close to what y'all were yelling about
but I mean if you can just do that at
the beginning at the beginning that's
right yeah I always tell folks don't if
you can now as an attorney you're
getting paid to enter into an octagon
together right yeah in a marriage I
always tell like don't have that fight
right now when you're mad that's not the
time to dissect what just happened same
thing with an email or a text yeah just
don't time has a funny way of just
clarifying yeah and it's not dissolving
it yeah like if I hold off on a text or
an email I said maybe I'll get an email
that's snarky from an opposing counsel
oh I have a response I'll type that out
here then all right delete delete and
then
within a day
I hadn't I don't need to say that
what I wish everybody like could really
chew on is that there's so much power in
that ability
to be able to know your own strength
inside of you that I nobody can make me
say anything that I don't want to say
and I have the ability to not react if I
if I so choose because what they said I
put in the trash Oh you wanted me to put
that on my plate that's funny no it's
the dog's eating them probably the
number one lesson I took away from
working with attorneys for all those
years was
that phrase there's power in the pause
and
the person who speaks last loses and it
was this like I don't have to say
anything right now I had never heard it
I love you you say it better like oh was
that for me because yeah is that
supposed to hurt yeah yeah yeah like oh
I'm sorry like oh is that your best uh
my bad right um but there's something so
powerful about
I'm not gonna say anything yeah oh yeah
I'm just gonna let it hang yeah it's a
and once you get the hang of it it
changes everything oh man it's it's it
is a game changer in your life it really
is and you know this when somebody
put something out there
well I had to do this and this and this
and your first word I love how you say
that my first word is breath yeah
just takes about 60 seconds before they
start going
well I mean yeah and then they'll you
see that Liars they'll reverse their
their they'll reverse the car all the
way down back the driveway oh yeah all
the way up that's exactly right like
people who who say something that some
would have a lie I want you to believe
something that's not true that it's you
just imagine them coming in hot in the
house they Park up to the garage and
then you don't respond
and the way and go away it is
he's not buying it
I'm gonna actually put this in Reverse
yeah yeah because I can't take that
silence yeah they can't take that side I
learned
um doing student conduct all those years
it became important for me to when I
would call a student in and say hey I
just got this report that you should
actually assaulted somebody are you
you're selling drugs or whatever yeah
I knew that by walking in my office
every fight or flight mechanism that
human had was set and so I used to
always walk them through everything and
then I would always end it with you got
24 hours from this point
you had 24 hours to come back and say
Here's what actually happened here's my
role in it and I'm going to count it as
though it happened here
because my end goal was I was trying to
teach students how to become
functional adults yeah and had a field
fight or flight and still tell the truth
anyway how to feel like ah yeah yeah and
then hang in there in the moment yeah
and I think if you have that same kind
of Grace with your spouse like the goal
here is not to win arguments the goal is
to have a great life to make a great
marriage and to raise great kids and if
we can always keep that thing in motion
then it might be we're gonna Circle back
up tomorrow right I feel often in in
spouse relationships and and I see this
on the legal side
it's not that they just want to call it
out they want you to they want you to
know that you're bad they want you to
know that you're not a good husband so
it's like they it's like they want you
to download
I think you're bad and I need you to
know it you don't feel it yeah and they
and nothing good comes comes out of that
I mean I am
if you take the position of I'm never
going to be the first to throw the first
stone because when the Microsoft
microscope you know turns on you
yeah it's you want that same you get
real quiet yeah that's right that's
right but there's something even about
if you if I'm sitting with a couple and
they've you know you got a Serial
cheater just infidelity infidelity
you're not making me leave
I'm choosing based on my values that I'm
not going to be with somebody who cheats
on me I am taking full ownership but I'm
ending this marriage that's right right
you didn't make me do anything yeah and
the more I can sit in that yeah I'm
standing up just explaining right right
you just sit up taller right yeah
um there's just strength and power in oh
you you can't make me do anything but
then you also have to choose I chose to
scream at that guy or I chose to try to
make her feel really bad yeah which is
just weakness and cowardice to be honest
with you I wish it was a different
language for it that's kind of weird no
no that's exactly what it is it's a it's
a reflection of your your lack of
confidence because most of the time when
we do have that that yelling reaction we
do say something that's snippy
if you're really honest with yourself
you regret it every time yeah and it's
not too long that you you regret and go
why did I say that and what you're going
to do you apologize and so often
especially manipulators kind of these
people that have very strong
narcissistic traits are masterful at
getting you to make these kind of
comments
so that then you are the one who is now
the offender you're the bad guy you're
the bad guy yeah I'm the one who came in
late through the door but you're the one
who can't appreciate this who always
nags about this and now all of a sudden
you find yourself the one apologizing
and also it depends like how you say it
well I need I I didn't like how you said
it you need to apologize for the way you
said your tone yeah your tone which is
also very true but the the people who
are masterful at it
with somebody who's not equipped for it
they'll they'll they'll run that song a
million times a day long yeah all right
all right so I want to take a a hard
left turn here okay wonderful from like
tactics and tools to just to you guys
have known each other for a long time
now it was a decade now as well and
kind of the reality you have reached a
level of personal success you own your
own firm you've got a team of attorneys
that work for you you've got a team of
staff that work with you and you guys
have an extraordinary reputation for
what you do right you come from a long
line of attorneys and there's kind of
this this sense that this is what
Jefferson's going to do right it's just
in the air right yeah so you've reached
level X financial success you reach
level X professional success you reach
level X with what I think is one of the
most important credentials on planet
Earth which which isn't a Juris
doctorate a JD a law degree from a
reputable American University
and then you go out in your car and you
start making Instagram videos yeah and
it goes from like 200 to 2000 to 5 000
to a couple of million right it goes
from dude some lawyers are passing this
around to oh my gosh this celebrity to
this celebrity to
The Rock gets in touch right right and
suddenly there's this moment when your
body goes
I've been warning you Jefferson for a
long time and we out yeah you're right
there yeah so walk us through there walk
us through what happened uh yeah I was
telling you at this at dinner you know I
I haven't I've never shared this with my
my audience before my followers I I
never expected any of this John like
ever ever and that was never the goal
just a guy making videos in his car
and when the account started
growing it's very easy just to say this
that's just pixels on your phone it's
not real it's not a real number
and because they're not there
and as it grew it still just felt fake
but when my account started to grow
I would tell like I would tell my wife
and she'd go that that's great okay so
are you able to pick up daughter at
swimming lessons right and and then okay
we need to make sure we have this
dentist appointment like that's that's
real world that's here that's that's
right in front of me yes they don't see
that yeah but as it started to grow
I remember working I was I put up my own
little website it's still my own website
that I just my Cracker Jack little box
that I had because I was like I need to
have something out and
I I looked at my phone
and it went over a million and I just
thought like
huh that's funny like you know what I
mean and then next notification I got it
said like the rock whatever I remember
looking at my phone
and just like immediately just putting
it down like I didn't either Dwayne
Johnson The Rock yeah yeah like Yeah The
Rock yeah I just I looked at it and then
immediately just like put it down like
that didn't happen like you just can't
do that so anyway I was I was working on
it
and like I told you it was
it was at 12 30 at night I'm like a
night owl I'm not not great at that
and I felt like somebody just wafted a
piece of like paper in front of my face
like a cold just flash and I said out
loud in my kitchen by myself I said what
was that
like I just remember looking around
going what was that
and all of a sudden I felt good good
like like everything my chest got tight
yeah everything just kind of hit all at
once and my body was telling me
something something ain't right
so it turned out I had my first panic
attack yeah that was terrible thought I
was dying
you are a world-class attorney yes whose
reputation has been forged on correct
I'm unravelable you got it I this this
whole row of Suits down here who all
make seven figures a year yeah come guns
and blazing and the other side of that
table is just freaking Jefferson smiling
at him right right okay right right
that's that's who you are well I've had
it it was like me at the council table
five of them jury like I'm like let's go
exactly you just have that kind of that
sense but and to be in your presence
just for it's like being in the presence
of a walking Xanax it's just like I come
in hot you know that like I'm like oh
hey everybody and it's like yeah so it's
it's awesome and so
for your body to be like hey man you
can't trick me I'll tell you this is how
Wild that was I've always been one my
whole life it's it's very family driven
too for reasons you and I know but
anxiety that's for people who don't have
their life together you're right that's
what I always thought it was I'm talking
I'm talking this happened this year
right this year yeah like in February
and when they told me
I was so convinced I was having I was
gonna die I was like any time lord any
time lord like when something's like
come on can you stop this it was a
horrible feeling because you had been
several days in a row right yeah I had
my first one and when they told me that
it was not a heart attack
oh yeah I thought I was dying I was I
was sure of it and when they said this
is how dumb I was I was so sure that I
didn't have anxiety or panic attacks
weren't a thing I was like I don't have
panic attacks that's how
strongly convicted I was that it was a
heart attack yeah because in my head I
was like I don't have that
sure enough my body said oh yeah you do
you're right right oh yeah you do and I
was so wrong and uh because of that I go
to therapy every week and I'm a I mean
I've gone to therapy in the past
but now my body's like no you you
actually have some stuff on your brain
that you're not you're not telling
people and it's it's such a healthy
thing and that I'm it would never be
embarrassed to share but after I had my
first pink Tech I had one for like a
week and a half every day but as that
happened I got better and better with
them gotcha how is that
um got a very similar situation yeah
like where I was Johnny Rockstar and
suddenly my body says hey I've been
trying to get your attention for a long
time and you're clearly not here and so
I'm we're shutting the system down
that's a great way to put it that's
exactly like you can't well I put like
when I saw that The Rock the followers
and I put that down in my head I was
like that doesn't bother me
and then my body was like it's the room
yeah my body's like the hell it does you
know what I mean yeah like all of a
sudden it was just like I don't they
have way too many eyes on what I'm doing
like for me to be a muscle
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-in life today for just 20 bucks at
John deloney.com
you and I live
um
not a traditional life right I don't
know right not now there you go but I
would say before this I was good in my
professional world yeah you're great in
your professional world right good what
we did and then this other thing happens
and there's a perception that
um if you are a mom who's a counselor in
a local community and you work 60 hours
a week and you've got two kids and
you're exhausted and your husband didn't
help that much but he's trying and
you're just making it right and you are
a plumber and you got four plumbers that
work for you and you have a small little
business and you've got two kids who
want little league and you're trying to
coach too right yeah there's this at
life we're running right yeah
the illusion is if I can just get here
if I if this would just happen if I
could get this dollar amount yeah the
whole thing is ah yeah right then I can
finally fill in the blank yeah and I've
come to wrestle with over the last few
years especially
that if then thing is a
it's a myth I knew that psychologically
if you'd come to see me like as a client
or just like yeah like I would have told
you that like that's not true but I
believed it it's so funny you mentioned
that like I'm like maybe this was maybe
three weeks ago talking with my wife and
she's we're at the kitchen an island and
she puts her hands down and goes I just
I'm ready for life to just to slow down
I'm just I'm ready for this to happen
this to happen and these things you know
in life is going to slow down
and I looked at her and I said this is
life I said this is it I said this
feeling this this this is what it is
it's never going to slow down there's
always going to be something like you
just need to enjoy this is exactly what
I told her you just need to enjoy the
present of where we are at any time
because there is no nothing to chase I
mean there's no there's not going to be
a well as soon as we get over this hill
we're gonna Coast yeah if you've got
kids if you got you know for your family
it's it's constant yeah it's on it's on
and it's on from the beginning to to the
end but yeah I was like this is it yeah
that's what I told her I was like this
is it there's no there's no we get here
and it's going to slow down well and
when you see that
okay here's the Calendar's got some
space in it that's when your kid breaks
their arm if that's when the teacher
calls and says your kid just said called
somebody a such and such and you're like
my kid right it doesn't stop yeah that
one weekend that you're like oh we have
it free and that's when somebody in your
family gets sick that's right yeah and
or your buddy calls and is like hey I
need a lawyer right now right okay here
we go right yeah some or something uh
you have a like we had a major storm
power goes out for like three days oh
okay I guess we won't be going anywhere
because y'all's Texas power grids yeah
duct tape yeah string yeah yeah and nwd
um so how has even in a limited time
going and sitting across from somebody
a mental health professional and saying
I'm not all right and beyond that not
just the act of going to counseling but
for a guy that had all the answers yeah
and not only had all the answers but
people hire you for your answers right
and you are a very particular type of
assassin
to be able to sit in that with that
skill set and go that doesn't serve me
here right
I need help here yes how has that
impacted you being a husband how's that
impacted you being a dad because I would
say arguably those are not arguably
those are the most important roles the
head of lawyer ahead of yeah Tick Tock
sensation but I know that
what it has taught me is
my mind can tell me pretty much anything
that I want to know and what I want to
say my mind is
like
it's it's it's very surgical in the way
it will help me control my reactions and
responses but it is a terrible doctor of
diagnosing what's going on in my body
and I've always been the type when and
you know this when you're in high
conflict situations your mind is what
matters like your mind is what keeps you
sharp I have to be listening to every
word that they say
but my body
my mind's gonna get out of here just hey
no no no yeah you're you're
not relevant right now I need your mind
and it's as Vandercook says it's keeping
the score right oh yeah yeah yeah
every day and that's what shut down and
so having these like deep dives into
where that's coming from and where I
found that was and I don't mind sharing
it was a just a sense of
being alone
and I say that because at the time you
and I weren't connected um and
nobody in my world could like relate to
what was happening in that space at the
same time it's I'm very just it's a it's
a privilege to even use the applications
they could inflict if Instagram wanted
to they could ban me and kick me off
tomorrow I have no free speech right
right there it's just they're like
thanks for using our app you know what I
mean like making us a bunch of AD money
yeah yeah that's it and
the the continuous
tense that I that I live in
you I could tell myself you're good no
you're fine just and I realized I was
not giving myself a lot of that
attention and permission as therapists
like to say give us a lot of permission
I remember being like permission or what
yeah like I didn't like that where I was
like can we not use that word
it turns out I was just
that was just Pride you know you were
deposing yourself yeah yeah yeah so she
was she was uh been great at when so you
realize you you do have a mind you do
have a body and your body is what is
suffering
um and you're not giving attention to
that and that's been that's been great
and and since then I've been it's made
me a better father to your question it's
maybe a better husband and that I'm
taking better care of my selfie actually
you know what you should probably go to
bed yeah how much of that is the answer
so many times that you know what calling
a friend and going to bed yeah yeah how
about you you're working out those three
sleep yeah you know what I mean because
you probably need that yeah and that's
and that's my evenings it's either I
need to have a conversation with my wife
to check in rather than us just both
going to bed I need to go to sleep or I
need to go work out and you know work
out that anxiety yeah it's not like
there's a Blog that is part of our
education yes and wasn't like somebody
just said hey read this book you're
going to have a
a bad crisis here in a little bit you
did have if I remember correctly an
extraordinary dean of students that
tried to tell you some of this stuff but
yeah he was a real pain but
God's the worst yeah yeah at that time
we weren't ready enough I mean I wasn't
either man yeah well I mean even even as
a student like so many times of like man
if I went back to that class I'd learned
so much it was I think in different
parts of her life were just not ready
yeah to absorb
you know we're not a sponge yet but or
or there's soil and those seeds get
planted and it just takes the right
environment for them to grow yeah so it
all grow a lot quicker yeah yeah maybe
they're just uh it takes them a long
time to produce anything that's right I
can't tell you I told you to dinner last
night
when I saw the success you're having
like my heart exploded in like uh
I've had the privilege of knowing that I
can just makes my heart so full so man
and more importantly you're not just
like getting famous you're actually
helping people you're handing people
tools like oh man and I think most of us
think our marriages our workplace our
relationship with our kids needs this
Grand sweeping thing yeah it usually
doesn't usually it needs I'm just gonna
start doing this a little bit different
I'm gonna start doing this a little bit
differently I'm gonna practice I feel
myself about to say something yeah first
word is going to breathe right I'm gonna
practice that yes and then you wake up
two years later and somebody says
something to just and your default
setting is a smile right and it's a
total that's when you go oh man yeah
yeah I'm changing right yeah I'm growing
I'm changing I got a comment not too
long ago and I love this one it's a it
was a wife she was saying hey I've been
following your stuff for a while and I
was in an argument with my husband it
was very stubborn hardheaded and we was
knocked down drag out and she said at
the end
I took a breath and followed what you
said and I said I can do better hmm and
she said
without a beat he said I can do better
too
she said never in any of our like 20
years of marriage has this man admitted
anything like that wow and it's just
like like what you said this was little
tweaks that's it it's usually the less
words the more impact that's right yeah
yeah that's awesome brother you're
awesome man congratulations thank you
all right thank you all so much for
joining me and my good friend Jefferson
Fisher please um go to Instagram and
follow him after you follow him follow
me too if you're not already and
check out some of his videos on how to
communicate more clearly how to
communicate better how to communicate
with your friends and family I can
assure you I'm trying to take some of
those lessons into practice
um because as you may have noticed on
this show I'm not always the clearest
communicator but
thank you all for joining us um if you
like interviews on the show let us know
reach out to Kelly reach out to Jenna um
go to John deloney.com ask and just put
interview at the Top If you like hearing
more if you want to hear more interviews
great if you don't if you'd rather just
hear from callers let us know that stuff
okay
um and like always I love you guys I'm
so so grateful for you thanks for being
with us stay in school don't do drugs be
nice be nice see you later
[Music]